uh the star of bethlehem isn't actually
mentioned explicitly in the bible
there's nothing called the star of
bethlehem
but there is a star that leads wise men
or magi to bethlehem yeah i mean it's
sort of often touted as potentially an
astronomical event that you know these
wise men coming from the east were
tipped off by some uh astronomical event
something going on in the sky
this is only in matthews it's only
spoken about in the gospel of matthew in
matthew chapter two but there initially
the star doesn't lead the magi or the
wise men to bethlehem at all it leads
them to jerusalem and there they uh well
they go to king herod who is the
ruler of the jews and he says to them
well i'm not sure and so he summons the
sort of chief priests and the scribes
and asks them where would the king of
the jews be born and they reply with
some words from micah
that he'll be born in bethlehem and so
this but over the years you know it's
one of those things that astronomers
like to play around with because
the nice thing is at least some things
in astronomy we can actually date
extremely well we can actually predict
when things happen like when planetary
conjunctions when planets come close
together in the sky and those kinds of
things so it's kind of been a a game
that astronomers have played from time
to time to try and predict what it might
have been
so they went to bethlehem
and
matthew introduces again saying that the
star guided them and was visible and so
with the help of the star in a way they
found a house and within the house
the mother and the baby joseph for
example is not mentioned at all in this
uh scenery there are lots of sort of
astronomical
predictions possibilities as to what
this uh this strange event was that uh
precipitated the wise men wandering all
that distance all it says about the wise
men is that they come from the east
those from the east are interested in
things like astrology astronomy maybe
there's no distinction between these two
um so it's surmised that because they've
seen this star because they've read the
symbols of the signs if you like and
said that this star means that a king of
the jews is to be born then it's
surprised that they are astrologers
uh as i say perhaps that you know the
one that's been around the longest and
perhaps the dullest is this thing called
a planetary conjunction where you have
say saturn and and jupiter very close to
each other in the sky
um and this is something that that
astrologers kind of get very hung up
about they think that it actually means
something of great significance when you
have one of these conjunctions
especially between the major planets
so this is the the sky
on
uh 12th of november 7 bc um
that you would have seen if you were
standing in the desert in bethlehem this
is a southwestern sky and you can see
saturn and jupiter very close together
in the sky it's like half a degree or a
degree separate so if you i mean
basically you know the planets are very
different very different distances away
from you and they're both orbiting
around the sun at their own speeds
and once in a while they just appear
close to each other in the sky they're
not obviously physically close to each
other but it's just one's more or less
behind the other so they're probably you
know within half a degree or so so
within about the size of the moon of
each other
this
meeting in a way was seen three
three times because of the the different
speed of the movement of the planets
although they just cross each other once
but it if you look from the earth it
looks as if they would meet three times
and this actually happens from
july till november this makes a lot of
sense
in
connection with ancient astrology
because the the planet jupiter and the
planet saturn they had a specific
meaning
and this meaning
can also give a kind of background for
the story in matthew the thing about
conjunctions is they happen all the time
you know there's one every few years a
major one every few years so it's not
very hard to come up with a major
conjunction occurring sometime around
the time that the wise men were probably
heading off towards bethlehem um and as
such you know it could be the
explanation but given that these
astrological conjunctions happen so
regularly why did that one cause such a
a major event in their lives and and
others didn't so jupiter is always seen
as a kind of kingly planet that means he
represents kingship because he's the
highest god in the roman pantheon and
saturn represents the ancient god of
cronus that means of time
the the meeting point of this two
planets
uh actually happened within the zodiacal
constellation of pisces
and pisces
was seen as a
representative of the land
of israel or of this area of syria
palestine within the or on the celestial
map and so that means a king
a time a time of a change of time
and the
land of israel and this makes it
understandable that this wise man that
means this astronomers coming from the
east
ask in jerusalem
who
or where is the new born king of this
country of the jews
those planets were very close together
the whole year long yeah this this is
now thought to be uh the the star of
bethlehem um especially because there's
i didn't show this but the um in the
ecliptic and the software doesn't show
that unfortunately in the ecliptic
there's a lot of dust so there would be
um
if you calculated this in there would be
a cone of light starting at certain
jupiter and then lighting going going
towards the earth
and so the other ones which are a little
harder to test is um there are various
things that occur
when stars blow up for example um so
there's these things called supernovae
which are kind of the death throes of a
star
and then there are no v which are kind
of events very late on in the lifetime
of a star that don't completely destroy
the style but a kind of the in in its
final stages of its life and these
things are
it can cause the objects to brighten
enormously so you can actually have what
appears to be a blank patch of sky
suddenly lighting up with a with a what
the ancients used to refer to as guest
star something which just lights up for
a few weeks or months and then goes away
again and obviously because these things
are a lot more random it's a lot harder
to test whether one of these things
actually happened in the right time
frame because you can't wind the clock
back the way you can with planetary
conjunctions and say oh yes one will
definitely have happened around then
but the both the koreans and the chinese
astronomers in that time frame were
actually recording these events and
there is actually they recorded one of
these guest stars appearing um again in
this right time frame of
just in the immediate years bc another
important place that we have the star of
bethlehem is on top of our christmas
trees so this is an excellent example of
a star there
and another comet which was a popular
one for a long time was halley's comet
which comes around very regularly in
fact it's a very famous painting uh by
giotto showing that the the adoration of
the magi and at the time giotto was
making his painting halle had just made
one of its appearances and so he
actually sort of borrowed it as
to stand in for the star of bethlehem so
there is a famous painting in which the
the star of bethlehem is in fact shown
as halley's comet
halley's comic came around in 12 bc
which is a little uncomfortably early
you know people want this event to be
happening sort of somewhere between 5
and 10 bc um so it's probably too early
for it for halley's comment to have been
the one but there are other comments
that just come through the once and it
could have been a comet